digital marketing has become an absolute
game changer for businesses all around
the globe turning it into a skill that
everyone wants to get their hands on it
is like having a superpower that allows
you to reach and engage with customers
on a whole new level if you have ever
dreamed of becoming a digital marketing
expert then you are in for a treat we
will be your digital marketing Mentor
guiding you through each step with
Clarity and enthusiasm from mastering
the fundamental marketing principles to
unlocking the secrets of advanced
strategies we have got you covered so if
you are interested in advancing your
career consider Purdue University's
postgraduate program in digital
marketing this comprehensive program
offers certification as a digital
marketer through live Interactive
Learning dive deep into fundamental and
advanced digital marketing strategies
utilizing Harvard Business publishing
cases and hand and on participation in
20 plus projects access the full
spectrum of digital marketing tools with
chat GPD and AI tools complemented by 35
Plus dedicated resources all right now
moving on to the next one that is PPC
advertising so let's start with the
first step towards becoming a digital
marketing expert which is learning
marketing fundamentals so learning
marketing fundamentals is like building
the solid groundwork for your digital
marketing Empire it's all about
understanding the inner workings of
consumer Behavior unraveling the
mysteries of market research and
uncovering the secrets of effective
marketing strategies think of it as the
key that unlocks the door to success in
the digital realm to get started immerse
yourself in the world of marketing
through online courses insightful books
and Industry blogs these treasure
troughs of knowledge will equip you with
essential tools and insights needed to
navigate the everchanging landscape of
digital marketing marketing once you
have gained the Basic Marketing
knowledge then the next thing you can do
is create a web page so imagine having
your very own Digital Playground a place
where you can Unleash Your creativity
and showcase your digital marketing
skills to the world that's exactly what
creating a web page is all about it is
like having a blank canvas where you can
paint your unique Brand Story and
Captivate your audience thanks to
userfriendly platforms like WordPress
and vix building a professional looking
web page has never been easier you don't
need to be a coding visit or a design
Guru to get started so once you have
created a web page you can start with
learning local SEO local SEO is vital
for businesses targeting a specific
geographic area optimizing websites for
local search results is key techniques
like optimizing Google my business
listings and obtaining online reviews
and targeting location specific keywords
are crucial by creating accurate and
comprehensive profiles on Google my
business businesses increase their
visibility positive reviews build trust
and credibility while location specific
keywords help businesses appear in
relevant local searches embracing local
SEO techniques ensures businesses
connect with the potential customers in
their area gaining a Competitive Edge
and driving grouth so learning local SEO
is also important the next step is SEO
on page off page to become a digital
marketing expert you must Master both on
page and off page SE technique
onpage SEO involves optimizing elements
within your website such as metatags
headings and content off-page SEO on the
other hand focuses on building high
quality backlinks and increased website
Authority through strategies like guest
blogging social media promotion and
influencer Outreach by understanding and
implementing these techniques
effectively you can boost your website's
visibility and rankings in search engine
results ultimately driving more organic
traffic and achieving digital marketing
success now the next step is one of the
most important step that is PPC
advertising So Paid media marketing like
PPC advertising is a GameChanger for
driving targeted traffic to websites
pick a platform like Google ads or
Facebook ads and become a master in it
learn the art of crafting compelling ad
campaigns conducting uh keyword research
and optimizing ad performance by
focusing on one paid media platform you
will gain the expertise needed to
maximize your Market marketing efforts
and Achieve outstanding results so dive
in and master your chosen platform and
watch your website traffic s after this
you can go ahead and learn the
analytical tools so analyzing data is
like having a superpower in the world of
digital marketing it's like a secret
source that helps you understand what's
working and what's not working to become
a digital marketing expert you need to
get cozy with analytical tools like
Google analytics these tools are like
Treasure Chest filled with valuable
insights about your website traffic user
behavior and campaign performance so
start by learning how to set up tracking
codes which act as a digital breadcrumbs
guiding you through the vast online
landscape then dive into creating custom
reports that give you a personalized
view of your data but don't stop there
the real magic happens when you
interpret the data and use it to make
informed marketing decisions so learning
analytical tools is also important if we
want to become a digital marketing
expert so now next is learning marketing
stack so learning about the marketing
stack is like unlocking a treasure Trove
of tools and software that can
supercharge your digital marketing
efforts picture it as a collection of
powerful weapons in Your Arsenal you've
got an email marketing platform like
MailChimp which help you craft
captivating campaigns that land right in
your audiences inbox then there are
social media management tools and let's
not forget about marketing automations
software like hubsoft which takes care
of repetitive tasks by gaining hands-on
experience with these tools you will
become master of efficiency streamlining
your marketing efforts and unleashing
your full potential after learning all
of these skills and tools you can go
ahead and learn Advanced topics first
programmatic advertising delve into
programmatic advertising which uses Ai
and automation to purchase and optimize
digital ads in real time understand how
it works and its application in various
marketing campaigns next is affiliate
marketing learn the Ines of affiliate
marketing where you promote other
Company products or services and earn a
commission discover how to find and
manage affiliate partnership
effectively all right now the third one
on the list is app marketing so in the
age of mobile apps knowing how to Market
them is crucial explore strategies for
App Store optimization inapp advertising
and user acquisition techniques so these
three are the advanced topics that you
can Master if you want to become a
digital marketing expert all right so
becoming a digital marketing expert
requires continuous learning practical
experience and a passion for staying
updated with industry Trends by
following this step-by-step guide you
can develop a strong foundation in
marketing Master essential digital
marketing techniques and gain experience
in advanced topics all right guys with
that we have come to the end of this
video If you like this video please give
it a thumbs up I hope it really helped
you all thanks for watching stay safe
and keep learning staying ahead in your
career requires continuous learning and
upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simpl learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here